There are various options of indexing.
And that gives NumPy
indexing great power.
NumPy array can be indexed
with other arrays.
It is just one other tool
which can be used to make
process of accessing
values in array easy.
To start with, we create a one
dimensional array of five random values.
Next we create a variable indices
which is also a one dimensional array.
But the elements of this array,
which is 1, 1, 2, 3,
are actually the index
we need to access.
That is, we want the value at index 1,
again at 1, 2, followed by 3.
Next step we learn how to use
this indices along with the edit
to access the desired values.
Yes, you saw that right.
Just passing the area of indices to
another area will give us the values.
Let's check the output.
So here is the output.
Observe that the length
of the indices array and
the returned array is the same.
Also it return value from
array a at index 1,1,2,3.
It is a bit difficult to understand
the application of this now, but
this is a tool you would like
to use once you get hold of it.
We can do such indexing using
multidimensional array as well.
But things get complicated with
creating multi-dimensional index array.
These are just a few
interesting ways of indexing.
There are a lot more out there for
you to experiment with.
Check the link in the instructor notes.